what's up guys breaking news a brand-new
amazing spider-man 2 trailer dropped
this morning let's talk about this
sucker we brought in a super cool panel
to help us break it down first he is the
writer of torso Manhunter Batwoman mark
and Draco
he's a mega comic fan and Andrew
Garfield look-alike Mike Carlson Peter
what do you think I thought it was
pretty cool
like it seems like it's really like
ambitious yeah I loved it I think it
looks right so I thought it was kind of
a badass detail to have the the vulture
wings and doc Ock's tentacles in there
what'd you guys think about that awesome
because we're getting like the Avengers
idea of taking these characters building
them up in a movie and they're all gonna
come together and they're gonna form a
team to fight spider-man and it is
obviously a child's dream yes oh my
that's really that's a really cool way
to put like an evil of well first of the
Avengers The Avengers were bunch of good
guys getting together to fight one
villain and this is a bunch of villains
getting together to fight one guy and I
just sinister say yeah it's really
really cool and like Mike said you know
that the 12 year old me is like the
sinister six awesome who is rhino in the
comics how does that and how does that
stray from the way it looks like it's
coming together here well in the
original comics he was the guy that put
on a rhino suit and broke stuff with his
head yeah you know just a big sort of
dumb guy and they've retrofitted him
over the years I think now his backstory
is that he's a Russian gangster enforcer
and that's what he is in this you see
chat Paul Giamatti all those Eastern
Promises tattoos and also as far as fun
actors Dean DeHaan I'd say step up from
James Franco you're gonna want to see us
why isn't that the question of the day
he's really got the good then a
chronicle of course he was great in
Chronicle we've already seen him play
evil megalomaniacal villains so I'm
really excited from the poster that's
online the the triptych post or the
villains you get the Green Goblin and
it's obviously deemed to Han they show
him and there's a monitor with his face
so right horns the Green Goblin which
goes against the comic books and against
the Iranian movies so we can get a great
look at Green Goblin yet the thoughts
about what we know so far so I want the
purple hood
I want the crazy Goblin face you know
what the mask they didn't use a mask use
is amazing look online for the onion
look online
while we're talking about the look of
characters
what about electro definitely different
from the comics and that's a bit of a
disappointment from somebody who wants
that weird crazy electric starfish on
the show yeah and like the yellow and
green
I mean imagine Jamie Foxx in that
costume but that the electro and the new
spider-man movie does look like that
electro they redesigned for ultimate
spider-man in the ultimate spider-man
cartoon so so they were trying to be
more practical with it
so guys what's gonna make you flip out
about this movie whatever it was the
ultimate thing we want to see if Andrew
Garfield s spider-man says wallop and
Webb snappers in a movie but that will
be kind of Awesome that would be amazing
um Mike well what would drive you crazy
about this would make you super excited
about it the whole universe building
thing yeah everything everybody's got
this universe building craze which is
why I love comics one of the reasons I
love comics and this thing continues to
build what looks like an awesome world
that's gonna be able to be explored and
then everybody's gonna come together
it's gonna be a big time Square fight
I'm gonna be very excited yeah
and it does look like an awesome world
this trailer for my money much better
than I expected
oh yeah me too me too and Sony announced
even that they're going to explore the
spider-man universe all those characters
and other and other films so yeah maybe
we'll spider-man 2099 movie Scarlet
Spider movie I wouldn't mind a
cloak-and-dagger movie or a black cat
movie I think those would be interesting
there's a lot of there's a lot of
characters off-the-beaten-path in the
spider-man universe that actually could
surprise people
I made a choice this is my path
so I think the jury is in we like the
amazing spider-man 2 trailer what do you
think about it and what do you want to
see from this movie leave an answer in
the comments section below best answer
huh you're gonna get a screen junkies
t-shirt also if you want to leave a
little message of goodbye or condolence
for my mustache or your favorite Hallett
mustache memory leave that in there too
I want to thank my awesome panel for
coming in here this morning mark and
Draco Mike Carlson follow these guys on
Twitter and hit me up on Twitter thanks
for watching I'm how Rutte Nick bye bye
how come the voice in honest trailers
sounds so seducing well that's the
opposite opinion of my wife maybe just
because I say booze so much I know